hey this is presh tal walker and you're
watching mind your decisions
here's a fun problem that's been going
viral on facebook and twitter
please email me any problems you see
that are going viral on social media
you have a rectangle with three circles
whose diameters are three centimeters
four centimeters and six centimeters
the question is
what is the distance a b
in the diagram
now many people sent me this problem and
i give a special thanks to the first two
people who sent it to me
thanks to riyadh tamala from tunisia and
shivam varma from india
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem
well first let's draw the center of each
circle
next we'll consider the radius of each
circle
the blue circle has a radius of 1.5 the
green circle has a radius of 2 and the
red circle has a radius of 3.
we essentially want the horizontal
distance between the center of the blue
circle and the center of the red circle
so we'll do that by considering the
horizontal distance between each of the
two circles
so first let's consider the center
between the green and the red circle
to do that we'll draw a right triangle
now one leg of this triangle the
vertical distance will be the difference
of the radii of these two circles
this leg will be the difference of 3 and
2 so it will equal 1.
the other thing is we know the
hypotenuse
because the two circles are tangent it
will be the sum of the radii
so the hypotenuse will be equal to two
plus three which equals five
we can now consider the horizontal
distance between the green and red
circles
by using the pythagorean theorem
this will be equal to the square root of
the quantity 5 squared minus 1 squared
and this simplifies to be 2 times the
square root of 6.
so we've considered this horizontal
distance which is one segment of a b
we now will figure out the rest of the
distance by considering the horizontal
distance between the blue and the green
circle
so we'll draw another right triangle
now in order to figure out the vertical
distance or one leg of this triangle
notice that this length is equal to 1.5
because that's the radius of the blue
circle
now the entire vertical distance will
equal 3 plus
so we can figure out the leg of this
right triangle as equal to three plus
three
minus one point five that's the radius
of the blue circle and minus two that's
the radius of the green circle
so this vertical distance will equal 2.5
that's one leg of this triangle
now the hypotenuse will be the sum of
the radii so it will equal 1.5 plus 2
which is 3.5
now we'll figure out the other leg of
this triangle using the pythagorean
theorem
this will equal to the square root of
the quantity 3.5 squared minus 2.5
squared
and this simplifies to be the square
root of 6.
so this will be the other horizontal
distance that we need to know
so now to figure out the length of a b
we simply add the square root of 6 and 2
square root of 6 and we get 3 square
root of 6 and that's approximately 7.35
centimeters and that's our answer
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video these
math videos which can be watched for
free on youtube inspire and build
confidence for people around the world
and they already have over 100 million
views please subscribe for free to get
the newest videos and email me a puzzle
or math topic presh
mindyourdecisions.com if you so choose
you can check out my merchandise which
is listed on teespring you can check out
my books which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon for exclusive rewards thanks for
watching and thanks for your support